what's going on guys
a huge moment is upon us a moment we've
all been waiting for Batman V Superman
that collision is hitting movie theaters
and we are going to give you a spoiler
free review the review will give our
feelings on the movie but they're not
going to be any plot points revealed
that haven't already been revealed in
the trailers and we have a couple of our
favorite screen junkies to talk about it
with first oh he's the movie fights
champion mr. Dan Merle and the bearded
Menace himself
Andy signor so gentlemen what you guys
think I think there's a lot to unpack
about this movie I think there's some
good things about this movie I think
there's some issues with this movie and
I think that it's going to be a great
discussion for months to come on pack ah
yeah something I'd like to lead with
everyone is wondering Ben Affleck as
Batman
are we on board I think a lot of people
are gonna be eating crow and I think
they're gonna have to admit that Affleck
was a good Batman ok I think we can
start there and say Ben Affleck does
deliver a strong Batman I want to see
him again
overall I'm excited about where this
Batman can go yeah Batman I love Jeremy
Irons is Alfred I thought that gal gadot
was good as Wonder Woman I look forward
to seeing more of her I like Henry
Cavill iced I never disliked him as
Superman but let me get back to Ben
Affleck because yeah and he's right
there our people are gonna be eating a
lot of crow including I think us when
that was like Oh Ben Affleck is Batman
yeah he's really good batfleck did it
for batfleck did it and what I liked
about Batman is this is a darker this is
a grittier this is a more brutal this is
a more violent Batman yeah we've ever
seen older older but what the movie does
set up really well what I wish they'd
gone into more is why and they explain
why which is that when you have a God
living amongst you people do get
resentful and they get angry because all
of a sudden now they are inferior
yeah and they feed that and they explain
that very well with Batman's character
as to why this is a more brutal version
I I don't mind that Batman was more
violent he is he warned he kills people
if you're not into that you're not gonna
like this Batman yeah but I was able to
look past that and see ok and I agree
with what Dan said like I'd like to I
didn't like Superman it made
to me the beginning of the movie is
fantastic when you see a flick all
that's sort of they're teasing them
going against the ruble and seeing the
carnage of Superman it's an amazingly
smart and awesome build-up and then you
got about two hours of various scenes
and things happening I'm cutting back
and forth and so many plots that could
have been taken away and didn't need to
be the movie yeah there are five movies
inside of this movie Wow there is a
sequel to Man of Steel this is about the
repercussions of what happened yeah
there's a solo Batman movie that's
setting up Batman there's a Batman V
Superman movie which is about their
ideological differences there is a Lex
Luthor movie which is about Lex Luthor
and his dislike of Batman and there is a
Justice League set up movie which is
about introducing characters from the
Justice League but there's nothing tying
it all together so just ruling so random
is like a one out it's like Game of
Thrones you're only in one episode
things like cuz they zoom around so much
yeah you don't have the history of
knowing who these people are investing
so there's ipping through so much than
like wait where am i where am i supposed
to stand and get grounded and got
connected to a character I couldn't
sometimes that style works because at
the end
oh there was a method to the madness it
all adds up to something you feel like
it did it didn't quite because they were
getting it's goal right because
it's not like they were develop
everything separately - all tied up
together they were giving short shrift
to everything gotcha
the best part for me in this movie was
actually this the inner my inner turmoil
of Superman where I just don't think
they focus any energy into it there's a
couple moments for Superman's wrestling
with at what do I do with my powers and
then you have this interesting idea of
the world pushing back and saying you
shouldn't be doing that and they never
really give you to you there's a point
where it's somebody they're doing
interview on TV and somebody asked this
question should there be a Superman that
is a great question that is a fantastic
question yeah that is a question that
should have had its own movie its own
manatee yeah - should there be a
Superman about exactly that thing we get
at what should we feel and learn the
Superman because I think cavil has a
great Superman and again we've we've
been saying this so people think we're
biased but it's like it's just they're
rushing it let me take a step back for a
second so you're saying it doesn't quite
add up as a movie what about being
immersed in this DC world
was I mean is that an experience stick
but they don't immerse you in it that's
the thing is is setting up the DC
Universe is given no more importance
than anything else in the movie uh-huh
other than Wonder Woman the Justice
League tie-ins in this movie a few in
particular are so lazily shoehorn into
the movie and just the most basic
literally the music cues like you're
like seeing I did it it it it it it it
you're oh okay here's the Justin Lee tae
in I feel a little bit like you're
telling me there's no Santa Claus or the
emperor has no clothes or something here
I still want to go in and see it I'm
still excited to see the man you should
in spite of you tell me there's no Santa
Claus I'm gonna go in that movie still
believing in Santa Claus
so I want to ask you some specific
things sure um was there enough action
Batman gets a scene that is amazing the
Batman Batman action ever it's off any
movie ever Batman swimmer fight is great
as well especially have you seen the
IMAX yeah
IMAX kicks in the full 70 millimeter and
then they start to fight there's no way
that that's not gonna be cool and
watching them fight is cool but it you
have to do more than just see them fight
it is a cool find be about it looks cool
there has to be more to it and the
substance of it the motivations behind
it are botched a little bit yeah what's
the end resolution of this is an
interesting moment okay and I have to
take Warner Brothers marketing to task a
lot here because for people saying that
like well the trailers didn't spoil that
much it that is not true
got real almost every major reveal every
major wine everything you saw and the
trailer is there okay that's a movie
here's another thing I'm really curious
about sure Lex Luthor Jesse Eisenberg
his portrayal and trying to be positive
here's okay what else how about here's
no say about Lex Luthor's whenever I
would ask me out Lex Luthor is missing
if you like the approach that you've
seen in the trailers mm-hmm then you'll
probably like him if you were worried
your worry was justified yes he went for
it he goes all out with it yeah but I
just found it to be distracting and
annoying one thing you guys have touched
on a little bit I want to know about gal
gadot and the portrayal of Wonder Woman
I was a fan yeah she's cool in the movie
I wish that we had at wonder when we
first because we see her do things that
would I think that a lot cooler if we
knew
what Wonderwoman could do exactly in
this universe she she is a force to be
reckoned with she is she kicks ass and I
really want to see this Wonder Woman I
want to see more this women room I think
the casting actually were we will yeah
she didn't need to be in this movie do
you feel that we're now set up for a
standalone Justice League movie poorly
I'm worried I'm worried I'll be honest
the choices made for the introduction or
the teasing of certain characters mm-hmm
is curious if it had got me excited I
would have been okay whatever yeah but I
know I didn't like them there's one
carrot there's one reveal in particular
that I was watching and I was just like
oh my god
yeah the way you're describing the
introduction those superheroes it's
reminding me a little bit of what I
thought about the amazing spider-man 2
and Rhyno at the end it's like you just
see a moment I thought I felt very
spider-man 2 they definitely needed
another Superman movie that's where I'm
frustrated because Superman movie with a
little bit of Batman would have been the
perfect to then build up which this
could have been a Justice League movie
they blew it I'm sorry but they did they
didn't deliver as well as they could
have because they were so concerned with
other stuff and it's a real shame
because I do I see three or four good
movies whole inside of this movie but
none of them are given enough time to
develop and it just becomes a hodgepodge
and and if I could just end with a plea
to to the fans of this movie and there
will be fans of this movie and and we
hear you and I would just ask that we
understand that there's praise for this
movie we have we share some of your
praise I would just ask that you not
bash our headed I'd love to have another
conversation with this longer when we
can talk spoilers and I think we've got
a way to do that either here on screen
okay calm yeah but I think it would be
nice to talk to the fans look I want to
know what maybe they can talk me into
figuring out what what were they
building that I missed well I know you
guys love this stuff and you want it
like you want it you go in wanting to
like it and I appreciate your honesty
and I will also say I'm still looking
forward to the experience I really want
to take it as you showed you shame to
you yes are you looking forward to it
are you excited about it are you a
little bit nervous let us know in the
comments section below so I want to know
what you thought about Batman V Superman
dan Merle thank you for your frankness
yes your candor
uh Andy signor always ring up and when
honestly I'm at Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter hit them up on Twitter thanks
for watching bye bye hey screen junkies
now that we've weighed in on Batman V
Superman you can weigh in on our own
epic contest the honest trailer for
Batman 89 vs. the honest trailer for
Superman 78 so click your favorite now
even on your phone and make your choice
your views will decide the winner and
determine a future honest trailer